at half past podcast without giving away
any spoilers what's one aspect about
kylo Ren you're excited for fans to see
in the next film ah but you could we're
not revealing anything but an aspect I
think I mean made this is such a general
answer but you know humanity even though
that's a very much a blockbuster movie
and I'm aware of that
there was no taking that for granted and
that we had that we were forced to be
general you know there was a lot of plot
points that we knew are operating in the
first one that we are kind that get to
explain more in the second one that kind
of make the both of them make sense but
that they do kind of feel kind of
socially active to me too in that
they're you know - and George Lucas is a
long answer but George Lucas you know
originally a lot of Star Wars was in
response to Vietnam and I think a lot of
what the I remember talking about what
JJ and Ryan was you know this this idea
of terrorism and two sides kind of being
morally justified to behave however they
wanted to to get what they thought was
absolutely correct
hey youtubers the year of hype is
started so kylo Ren teasing his
character in Episode eight let's break
it down there is a new round of the Star
Wars giveaway it's for IMAX gift
certificates all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video be sure to click that Bell
to enable alerts so you don't miss
anything so what is he saying here
there's like a Lucasfilm person off in
the distance that you can't see with a
sniper rifle on him just careful not to
get away
super big plot points but he actually
says a bunch of stuff so number 10 he's
basically saying we're gonna see kylo
ren's humanity in episode 8 meeting that
we might get like a full blown
redemption of kylo Ark by the end of the
series which might not be a huge
surprise like he goes into this big
speech about the original conception of
the character with the producers how
they wanted to show a bunch of people
tackling the same problem of bringing
order to a galaxy in chaos from two
balanced perspectives now we use the
word balanced but the first order just
totally came off like fascist they
massacred a bunch of people with a giant
Death Star weapon he even killed his
father so even though the first order
kylo Ren Snoke are definitely the
antagonists of the new trilogy they're
gonna do a good job of providing a
balanced perspective like why it is the
kylo Ren believes that what they're
doing is the right way of doing things
so number 9 bringing order to a galaxy
in chaos very darth vader original
trilogy approach to what kylo ren is
doing now which makes sense because he's
a vader fanboy he carries the melted
helmet around with him the ashes that he
puts it in there are actually the ashes
of the people that he's defeated they
left that detail out of the movie but it
just lets you know how hard quarry is
but those aren't Vader's ashes just the
helmet belongs to Vader number eight
talking about some more of the context
that he said that they're going to be
adding how did he come to be with
Supreme Leader Snoke
so they actually explain a little bit of
that during the expanded materials and
the books that they released like if you
bought one of the look books you
actually learned a little bit more about
the characters than you would in the
movie so they described kylo Ren is
someone that has an identity crisis
growing up just because of who his
family is his parents are a big part of
the resistance forming this new
government the galaxy is kind of in
chaos so he himself has an identity
crisis
and in that moment of weakness supreme
leader snoke seeks him out and takes
advantage of him just like a cult leader
would feeding him promises giving him
the feeling of purpose and family that
he felt like he wasn't getting from his
real family but his Adam driver
describes him like he still feels the
pull of the light side so number seven
why did he have to kill Han Solo in the
movie the biggest reason for that is
that his family was a big tether for him
to the light side of the force he wanted
to get rid of that so he felt like he
had to kill his father although really
it was Snoke pushing him in that
direction in a reverse version of what
Luke Skywalker had to go through like
the test that he had to face Vader and
confront the idea that he was his father
like he had to come to terms with that
that was one of the final tests on his
path to becoming a Jedi not just
fighting Darth Vader but also coming to
terms with who Vader was and what that
meant about himself about Luke so kylo
Ren had a reverse version of that so
when he's having the speech with obi-wan
Kenobi getting ready to go to Cloud City
to save his friends kylo Ren has the
same version of that speech with Supreme
Leader Snoke here where he kind of
feigns the problem like oh this is gonna
be a big test for you you've never faced
anything like this even though you're
the master of the Knights of Ren there's
been an awakening
have you felt it yes there's something
more the Droid we seek is aboard the
Millennium Falcon in the hands of your
father han Solo
it means nothing to me even you
master of the Knights of Ren have never
faced such a test by the grace of your
training I will not be seduced we shall
see we shall see so you could argue that
kylo Ren didn't totally pass his test in
the way that Luke didn't totally pass
his test either like he came out of it
with one less hand and just could barely
process the idea that Darth Vader was
his father
so kylo Ren is able to kill Han Solo but
that doesn't magically cut him off from
the light side of the force
JJ Abrams did explain after the movie
came out that it's sort of like wounded
him in a spiritual way so it weakened
him because it was such a heinous act so
that kind of informed his lightsaber
fight with Rey at the end like he was
weakened spiritually from killing Han
Solo but he also got hit with the bow
caster blasts so he was physically
wounded so he was like gravely wounded
even though it didn't really come across
with the performance like you kind of
get the sense that he's wounded but he's
a Vader fanboy so number six now that
he's done this he's going to dig his
heels in and double down on the dark
side of the force even though the light
side isn't totally dead inside him
remember we're gonna see his humanity
meaning that if there's still Humanity
in him there's still the light side of
the force inside of him so redemption of
kylo Ren so number six more context
there's just so much we don't know about
what precipitated what's happening in
Episode 7 we get flashes of it when Rey
touches Anakin's lightsaber we flashback
to the Jedi Academy massacre you see
kylo Ren with the Knights of Ren de
looks like they've come back after some
absence he has his red lightsaber so
whatever's happened he's taken on his
dark side persona and come back to get
rid of the Jedi in the way the Anakin
came back and massacred all the children
at the Jedi Temple
so whereas with episode 3 you sort of
saw all the moments leading up to that
you saw the Emperor tell him to go take
care of the younglings like he basically
told him go kill all these people you
didn't really see that with kylo ren's
character so we'll get some more context
for that what led up to that moment why
it is he left the Jedi Temple
if Supreme Leader Snoke is such an
a person Luke Skywalker would probably
be aware of him and keep him away from
the Jedi so there are a lot of character
beats in story beats as well that
Episode seven skipped over that episode
eight will add context for speaking of
which number five the Knights of Ren so
everybody's wondering about them the way
they explain it is that they're not Sith
but it's basically like another aspect
of the religion of the force like they
introduced the idea of the Church of the
force rogue one actually took a more
religious perspective of the force
itself so just like all religions have
their deities everyone has like very
different ways of worshipping the force
and using it so the Knights of Ren is
just meant to be like another dark side
spin off in the way that the Sith was
just like another sect of dark side
users but a lot of you wondering like we
saw that really badass castle on mu
stefarr that belonged to Vader it was
built on the ruins of an ancient temple
or an ancient structure that was very
strong in the dark side of the force so
it would make sense that kylo Ren would
start retreading a lot of Darth Vader's
path just because he's so obsessed with
him I feel it again
ultra light
supreme leader senses it
show me again the power of the darkness
and I will let nothing stand in our way
show me grandfather and I will finish
what you started
he's almost on the exact same mission
with the exact same plan that Darth
Vader was on so even if we don't see it
in Episode eight I wouldn't be surprised
if at some point during his training he
visited that place but we'll see
wherever it is the Knights of Ren are
actually finishing their training
because that's what Snoke says at the
end of Episode seven he tells general
Hux to get kylo Ren bring him to me so
that we can finish his training the
collapse of the planet has begun leave
the base at once and come to me with
kylo Ren it is time to complete his
training so number four what is Snoke
trying to do with kylo Ren what does
that train was the whole point of it so
the way they explained it like all the
expanded materials the lookbooks is that
he's trying to create a super Jedi from
a fallen light side Jetta because he
feels someone touched by the light side
could ultimately become a more powerful
Jedi than someone who was just a purely
darkside force user so if you didn't
read the expanded universe books there
was a character called Jason solo he was
one of the twins born to Han and Leia
who became something of a super Jedi
himself by learning to harness both the
dark side and the light side of the
force so they called it the unifying
force it's like a much more broader
perspective of how the force works and
they are kind of doing that on rebels a
little bit this season but they call it
the Ben do Jedi a Masood the light and
the dog
I'm the one in the middle the band knew
once a secret is known cannot you you
have Dark Jedi on one side you have
light [ __ ] on the other the Bendu is in
the middle and has a slightly broader
perspective of what the force is
so yes Snoke wants to subjugate the
galaxy the way the emperor does bring it
under control but he also wants to
create a super Jedi so you wonder if
like he and Ray are on parallel arcs if
the same thing is going to happen from
Ray's perspective like if she'll be
pulled to the dark side of the force and
they'll both become these crazy Jedi
that wield both the dark side and the
light side of the force
number 3 speaking of which what is the
history between kylo Ren and Rey because
he definitely knew who she was when he
learned that they were on jakku anything
else the two were accompanied by a girl
what girl
Shelagh he freaked out at the thought of
a girl a forced user so he probably knew
her at the Jedi Academy she seems like
she's quite a bit younger so like when
he's here massacring all these Jedi
she's like the little girl here that
they drop off on jakku so on the surface
you know still pending what her true
identity is it seems like they just knew
each other at the academy and she
survived the massacre and he's upset
about that but there are all kinds of
theories about who raised parents art
maybe she's related to obi-wan Kenobi
somehow maybe she's related to the
Skywalker's so the lad more context for
that as well how she came to be left on
jakku by herself because presumably if
she was going to be hiding out on some
desert planet they would leave her in
the care of someone like an obi-wan
figure someone to watch over her from a
distance and she really didn't have that
like there were people that kind of
looked out for made sure she didn't die
but she didn't have an obi-wan Kenobi
like Luke Skywalker head number two what
about Supreme Leader Snoke where was he
when all the stuff during the original
trilogy was happening because he looks
very old twisted by the dark side so
just like the Emperor he was very strong
in the force but if all this stuff was
happening with the Emperor and the
Empire during the original trilogy what
was Snoke doing so based on the way the
expanded material describes him he was
just kind of waiting for his opportunity
he has a different approach to the dark
side of the force than the emperor had
so he was just off practicing his force
magic off in a different part of the
galaxy just watching all this chaos
unfold waiting for the galaxy to crumble
so he could just walk in cherry-pick the
stuff that he wanted which included the
remnants of the empire which became the
first order in then kylo Ren like they
said that he had a longtime fascination
with the Skywalker lineage so when he
saw the opportunity to nab one of the
Skywalker children someone who flowed
from the lineage of Darth Vader he took
it so it wasn't like he just stumbled
upon kylo Ren like he'd just been
waiting for an opportunity to take him
from his family for number one what does
this mean about endgame and when are we
actually going to get some footage so
the footage stuff is a little bit easier
to explain mark hamill teased that he's
going to give a first look at episode 8
on his show pop culture quest he didn't
say when that's going to happen sometime
soon presumably but I think the
actual footage won't drop till Star Wars
Celebration in the spring so just set
your calendars for that for like an
actual trailer so get hype it's going to
be awesome if 2016 was the year of zero
chill then 2017 is going to be the year
of hype so I'll say congratulations to
the latest Star Wars giveaway winner
Ulysses Adkins you want a pair of IMAX
gift certificates be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details there
is a new round that started in this
video so because my next video will be
Star Wars princess leia i'll just
announce the winner when i post that
well you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for my thor ragnarok
Planet Hulk preview and you can click
here for all my rogue one Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys in the next video
me me me me me me
[Music]